the coronavirus effects each of us we're
changing our way of life to protect our
own health and that of others we may
miss many things that are dear to us but
we don't miss the air pollution from
cars or the noise of traffic when we
throw open our windows we can breathe
fresher air we see nature restoring
itself but we shouldn't fool ourselves
we may be getting a better grip on the
coronavirus but we are not getting a
grip yet on climate change the warming
of our planet continues and it will warm
even more if we continue to burn fossil
fuels as we know plan to slowly go back
to work and to invest billions of euros
to restart our economy we should avoid
falling back in old polluting habits
instead we should bounce back better
from this pandemic we can make our
society and our planet healthier by
investing in renewable energy by driving
clean cars by renovating our houses and
making them energy-efficient by buying
sustainable food reusing materials
rather than throwing them away a
producing low carbon steel this is the
essence of the European Green Deal the
European Green Deal is an agenda for
transforming our economy to make it more
competitive and improve our quality of
life we will now also make it our motor
for the recovery by using the European
Green Deal as our compass we can turn
the crisis of this pandemic into an
opportunity to rebuild our economies
differently and make them more resilient
so that we also leave a better place for
our children with a green recovery we
will come out of the crisis stronger and
healthier